[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to an
extra long girthy episode of honest
trailer commentaries
i'm here with law and i'm here with
danielle uh i've got someone picking up
some craigslist furniture around noon so
that's my hard out
but otherwise we are here to watch the
scenario cut honest trailer together to
give your
behind the scenes thoughts to give you a
little more detail into what we were
thinking
what we're uh discussing uh in the
writer's room
we're gonna watch some deleted scenes we
are going to what else do we have we
have deleted scenes we got questions and
comments from viewers like yourselves
and then we've got a clue for next
week's honest trailer should you
forgive us in your heart and come back
to watch another episode
it feels wrong to have deleted scenes on
the snyder cut honestly
we should have just grafted them onto
the honest trailer
that's part of the that's an excellent
point yes um
disappointing so yeah i mean if you want
to watch us experience it for the first
time
watch our uh go on phantom entertainment
and watch our our watch party that we
had for this thing but obviously
we all went back and privately entered
our batcaves
hit play and rewatched it several times
on our on our lonesome so how did you
guys feel about the
your your second and beyond viewings uh
in a more calm setting without as much
mountain dew
of the snyder cut how did you guys feel
after that um you know i still
uh when i when we watched it with the
mountain dew i said that
you know it's definitely a better movie
and makes it a much better movie for me
but it isn't the movie for me and i
think watching it
again um without distractions
and just like fully engaging in the
movie again very very good there are
great parts to it things that i enjoyed
i liked it better than the other one
but it's just it's not like great it's
good
it's a good movie but at four hours i
will
never do it again yeah i i think the
the the ideal version of
the justice league movie would be one
that we'll never get to see and
this is not a challenge or a dare i'm
saying we're never gonna get to see
it not that i want to or we should but
it would be if you did not take the
movie or the movie did not leave
the hands of zack snyder and go into the
separate hands of joss whedon
and if instead we took this cut and we
we whittled it down into a releasable
two and a half hour
two hour and forty minute maybe movie
and i think there is
this feels like the the clay and we need
to keep cutting it down more to get to
the statue it's like on its way
but it's not there yet and i think that
it it's not
in its current form it's like i'm glad
that it's out and it's exhaustive but we
get to see everything that he was
planning
but i think there's a probably a pretty
good two and a half hour movie in here
that we're just
like that's it's stuck in the middle of
a lot of stuff we really probably don't
need to see
yep yeah and i think um i'm probably
just gonna echo what both of you said
is like i'm super happy to see this
movie and super happy that it exists
because
this is definitely the undiluted vision
of
one man um and this is it like that's
that said like i just think that the the
approach he has
to um the dc characters and to
and to filmmaking like it's amazing
visually i just still
i can't connect with them
with looking at the dc pantheon as
unapproachable gods as like these as the
titans like literally fighting next to
the titans of mount olympus
like there was zeus there was uh ares
and there was a green lantern like
they're literal gods
um i don't know maybe it's because like
uh you start off life
uh at a person around our age uh with
like the joel schumacher batman's or
like
you know dc in that era was like
patently silly
and has been for so long that to to to
see his
such reverential take on these
characters and
uh four hours of it is just like it's a
little bit
silly to me but i'm super glad that he
got to do it
um i'm super glad that he got to
actually uh uh
leave his mark on this franchise and say
like you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna throw everything at
the screen like i think he thinks
in visuals first i have a hunch that he
thinks like
how cool would it look if superman was
fighting the rest of the justice league
how cool would it look
to see uh you know do dark side
uh uh you know in his element and stuff
like that and then kind of works
backwards from there
and man the visuals are awesome they
really are like like
frescoes of like an ancient greek temple
and stuff like that
but i don't know it it just doesn't it
doesn't resonate with me
uh uh on like an emotional level uh it
seems like there's such a distance
between you it's like there's the gods
up here
and then you the little people down here
were just ants scurrying around you're
either a god or
a bug man riding around for steppenwolf
and i just find it hard to connect with
that for four hours but i'm still glad
like i said i'm still glad that he got
to do
it and that this uh this film exists
i feel like uh there is a and this runs
through
all of his dc like the full snyder verse
of dc films
there there it seems like he's kind of
counting on
you know superman you love superman you
know wonder woman
you care about her innately because of
who she is
it's a costume it's an icon it's powers
it's beyond and so we don't need to
emotionally connect with them they're
just these icons and and it's not that
we don't emotionally connect like
some characters he obviously does want
you to emotionally connect with in these
movies like
lois lane cyborg in this one uh
so it's not it's not like i'm trying to
say this is a knock on him as a
filmmaker like
i think dawn of the dead's another good
example like he can't invest in a
character
it's just often he kind of doesn't want
to and in this movie it really feels
like
he doesn't want to engage with bruce
wayne as a man bruce wayne
is here to be a symbol and will engage
with alfred as a man who like he's our
mortal version of it it's kind of like
what you were saying about
their gods and i don't know i just i
that that just never works for me i
always want to get to know the heroes
as people with personalities and quirks
who grow like nobody arcs in this movie
except for like cyborgs
i guess
this is all on a spectrum because i
think that um obviously
marvel movies do this but they try
sometimes too hard to make them like
spider-man he's just like us where like
every character no matter what dire
situation they're going through
is always kind of you know hey we're
just buddies right oh there goes the
planet whoops oh
that's awkward like they can obviously
take the weed and ease the the joss
whedon of it all
way too far um i just think when you
combine i mean that's kind of the
fundamental marvel versus dc like if you
were talking an incredible shorthand
about
well what's the difference between the
marvel and the dc universes like this is
it
dc is like these you know like stop
evildoer like it's that
classic kind of notion of a superhero
and then marvel was the reaction to that
which is like
what if the superhero was just like the
nerdy kid in your class like
and like i this is not you know always
true or a law or one to one like there
are plenty of relatable dc
characters and plenty of marvel like
stop kind of characters but that's the
the fundamental divide and i think it's
particularly stark when you're talking
about
joss whedon's approach to something like
the avengers and then zack snyder's
approach to something like justice
league
yeah uh daniel any further thoughts
before we dive right in
now i know i'll have some as it's going
through yeah we'll we'll talk plenty
more as it's going
um uh and yeah i think we'll just ramble
on for
uh for hours as we could as as you
should for a movie like the snyder
county i'll tell you one thing that
repeatedly while i was watching it for
the second and then ultimately yes folks
third time was uh jeremy irons i would
just like
because he was there like he's on set
like bringing tea
in the background to like all the
team-up scenes where they're all at the
batcave making their plans and like
oh to be sitting next to jeremy irons on
set just like getting his
moment-to-moment thoughts about this
film and the story and the other before
like
i'm sure that was amazing i would love
to hear just
his own commentary about what he's
experiencing yeah i mean
i'm i can't wait for uh was there a
making of doc
that they came out yes at the same time
no i think when this went up on hbo max
they also put up
some kind of behind the scenes making up
thing right i haven't watched it i still
haven't watched that i i i
i should i should tag that on anyways
well uh let's start watching the actual
australian
zack snyder demonstrating how to crack a
neck to every actor individually
hit that like at least 90 degrees
from the director of the justice
league's trailer
comes the film that rose from the ashes
to redeem that burnt orange tire fire
transforming it from a movie that was
two hours long
and terrible to a movie that's four
hours long
and mediocre proving once and for all
if you want to look great by comparison
just stand next to joss whedon
the snyder cot for real this time
so pause i mean it's impossible to
separate
how you feel about this movie like i
wish i could have like you said lon just
seen this one like in a vacuum this was
the only version of this film i saw
because like
you just have to you see so many things
and you're like well that's better and
that makes
more sense um but that's such a low bar
that's such a low part to step over
yeah i mean i feel like i there's
there's two things going on there which
is one
i don't envy the task that joss whedon
was handed like this movie and then
you're given it and say okay it needs to
tell this exact same story
you can't really shoot that much that's
new a little bit here and there
but it has to be two hours super funny
and colorful like what no
it's not positive so so there was that
which was he was handed a very difficult
task
but then there's the other half which is
every decision he made for the most part
is bananas and wrong and like one
prime example that you could visually
see right there that i thought that
kevin did or
yeah i think it's kind of uh whoever did
that that wipe
across uh why would he decide to make
the entire finale
orange like it's such a when you see it
look
normal in this and it's cool it makes it
extremely bizarre
that that would like i get that they
probably said they wanted it to look
more colorful for a trailer
but like that's a bananas to see like
what are you doing it looks horrible
danielle whitehorn like cg like worm
tentacle ruth things coming out of the
ground it's like
it's crazy to go back and watch what
whedon did with that scene versus the
original one
like that makes no sense well and
especially because
the way that all of this was framed kind
of at the time there's a lot of stuff
that obviously like we all did not know
so it felt for a lot of people like
okay this is going to come in and this
is going to make this into the franchise
that i wanted it to be like i want to
see my heroes look a certain way
um and so to have that kind of
expectation of like oh yeah it's going
to be great joss is going to do is going
to be amazing
and then you get in and
it was you know the kind of
frankensteining
that they did together i can't think of
anything
that had more in like where the
enthusiasm was just popped
almost immediately because it starts
with that weird mouth scene
um so just like immediately
going from being super hyped because
you're a fan of of these characters and
you're a fan of this new director
and then just having your hopes dashed
and then still having to be in the
theater for another two hours
he also at the the opening of the weed
version so first you get the bizarre
like the baby mouth yeah the baby mouth
thing and then you get that seed of
batman
and mind hunter actor i forget colt
mcneary
and he's like using this random guy is
bait to lure one of the bug
the paradise and then it shows like
boxes on the wall that and i guess he's
trying to condense but it's just like
that scene made no it's so bizarre and
you could tell it was reshoots and then
you see it here and it's just like
what there's so much stuff that they
already shot explaining
parademons and mother boxes like why
would you shoot this new
dumb see it's just oh you have five
solid minutes of superman screaming as
he dies
yeah like it's it's always stuff like
well i get you couldn't just do what
this was because it's a four-hour
juggernaut of storytelling but i don't
get why it turned into what it turned
into
yeah all right keep going
prepare for a film that wouldn't exist
without a powerful league uniting behind
it
joining the internet's most devoted fans
of targeted harassment
creatively bankrupt wb execs a parent
company who would happily piss on the
ashes of the last movie theater
to sell more broadband the writer who
sharted out rise of skywalker
and a director who was already
self-indulgent before he formatted a
film for imax
knowing it would be released on a
streaming service i think he just liked
how the bars added more darkness to
every scene right
that's free darkness right there baby
all right pause i mean it was an amazing
just
confluence of events it was it was a
convergence of the spheres
uh for this movie to happen i think that
if if any one of those things
doesn't come together um i don't think
we get to see it
right like the pandemic like causing hbo
max to
launch without anything that they could
really film and they have this
a t and t being like screw it we just
need sign ups um
uh and the fans i mean the snyder cut
bravo
you know you guys you just wanted it
more i'm not i'm
not included in the clapping that that's
not that
backlapping is spencer exclusive no
you know what they say after after
sports games like the other
the other side just wanted it more they
they had more hustle
they really yeah good game good game
they definitely
wanted it but it's just it's just it's
just going to keep going at some point
these people are going to realize like
this is not going to fill the void in
your life like well no movie
no no nothing nothing can you're just
gonna have to you're just gonna have to
go on zoloft like the rest of us folks
i'm sorry
no gal gadot uh deleted scenes are gonna
do it for you
uh yeah i just think it's um we're
living in just a very
rare and unique timeline in the
multiverse where uh where all these
things
kind of uh happened right
there's a there's probably a normal
there's universes where we get different
versions of the snyder cut or he
just keeps making the movie originally
but to get the four hour long one
on a streaming service is just like
that's yeah that's thanks to like some
pangolin in china we also have to like
i think you also have to look at like
what an odd situation like
dc warner brothers has always been like
usually there's the
the the com the comic book or the
publisher the owner of the ip
and it's sort of separate from the
studio and you get this like
extended relationship partnership
negotiation
like disney and marvel uh and that
doesn't happen like like warner brothers
just
owns it and warner brothers executives
get to like make up their mind what to
do with dc
and then they all get fired and a new
group comes in and they get to make up
their mind about what to do with dc and
a lot of times it's like totally
different from what the guys
or the girl of what everybody five or
ten years ago thought and so you always
get this cycle of reinvention that's
very unique in terms of like how these
stories get told
and so you're always kind of in a
situation where this could happen like
well the last regime
was going this way and we're going to
come in and go
completely the other way you know and
it's like always these fascinating sort
of
reversals where you go from like the
schumacher movies to the nolan movies
you know like
and i think that's really fascinating to
look at if you're looking at the history
of
dc adaptations as opposed to marvel
where there's you know more like people
steering the ship who try to keep a
relatively consistent vision
yeah and this was just again like a
historical
accident i think where because i i don't
think there was
like a real stable executive core and a
real vision
at the helm they were like zack for
these for man of steel and for batman
for superman
do your thing like we we are giving like
a filmmaker carte blanche to like do his
interpretation
of of dc there was no feige giving him
uh notes like oh we actually have to
like make it work with all this other
stuff like he
really got to do you know the the
objectivist uh hunky hunky
the hunky objectivist version of
superman we didn't call it up but that
that newspaper headline as i let
everybody know in our slack chat
is an ein rand shout out in the the
snyder cut of the job yeah and his he's
talking about how his dream project is
to make the fountainhead
and i think that's probably why like
again like there's plenty of art that i
love that i don't
agree with quote unquote but it's like i
just can't connect
to superhero movies where the core
question is like should we help all
these
all these losers all these losers that
don't deserve it
i'm really good like like kevin costner
jonathan kent in man of steel
you do see how that kind of plays in
where he's like listen if it means
revealing yourself maybe it wasn't worth
it it's like
that bus full of kids that i just saved
are you sure dad
like i mean maybe you make the call and
in this film yeah we
will probably get to it but like it kind
of implies that the only thing
keeping superman from snapping and and
taking over the world is
is lois lane is like
literally the flash goes through time to
tell batman that
lois otherwise superman
yeah otherwise superman thinks we are uh
we're bug men we're the little pair
demons just buzzing around for him to
squat a lot
like i think that we've we've yet to
have the conversation about
how so much of all of these movies the
entire snyder verse
really feels like that zach just
is fixated on the idea of bad superman
like it's just
it's such a it's such a focus for him
there's a lot of nightmares but i mean
that seems to be like uh
that's the groundwork of his trilogy
quadrilogy whatever it was going to be
we're building up to superman turning
evil right it seems like the the
tension is always just i need superman
to be evil but i also need it to not
break
dc continuity like you can't just do
else worlds you can't just do
injustice it has to be like we're in the
dc universe prime
and also superman is evil which is hard
to do because he's not evil
so i mean i kind of wish they'd done
them or maybe a dream sequence now or
something happens you know the more
explicit
uh that the comics version of the
anti-life equation is
literally an equation that just proves
that free will is an illusion so like
once you understand the equation like
well i guess it's an illusion i just
have to follow darkseid now
just shown that to superman and he's
like well this all checks out yeah his
eyes just turn red turns
also he does have super math abilities
so that makes sense
yeah yeah all right let's keep going
we're going by the earth's yellow sun
we're only at part two let's keep going
black suit up for an entirely different
take on the theatrical release
except for its plot setting main
characters and themes
where if you recall a gracie gi monster
covered in spikes
wants to destroy the world who's out to
impress his grey cgi monster boss
but this time follow in excruciating
detail
as this grey cgi monster reports his
progress
to his grey cgi monster bosses gray cgi
monster executive assistant
decide design i called to thee i
found one of the three the one that woke
and called let me make a plea to him
that i may come home
after i take the combined power of the
two mother boxes
i've been able to finish before
i'm gonna put this on on chris tario
because i feel like this is the same
thing as rise of skywalker where so much
of the film is just laying pipe for like
why where the little booble boxes are we
gotta find the key to unlock the door to
get to the thing to get to the planet so
much of it is like
he really dwells on logistics and
uh lets you know in excruciating detail
how each step of the treasure hunt is
going and how it's going to go and what
needs to happen
and i feel like people they don't trust
people enough to get it by context or to
just understand
well these things are important they
gotta find it or else something bad
happens it's also
cooler to not show us so
much like this was a real lesson of the
mcu like
you you sprinkle a little bit of thanos
here and there you don't get we didn't
really get to know him at all until
infinity war it's just like
oh well that's who ronan's working for
and there's one scene or oh loki talks
to him and space almost stopped that
behind the throne that one time and like
that's what gives it mystique and allure
and makes it cool and interesting and a
tease
whereas if you show us like 20 minutes
of dark side waiting around
next to an old lady like what's going on
on earth and then
i mean not just that not just that one
like that yeah the first time you meet
darkseid is him getting
uh he's actually kicked by his ass
kicked even though i love david
yeah i love that scene i'll always take
a dh through listed in the movie
give me a d aged thoughtless in this yes
uh
but yeah i think as far as introducing
your big bad goes there there
there are other ways to do it uh aside
from having him
almost die and run away right and and
and to all you leaving the but
he didn't have his own mega beams in the
cut in the comments like yes we know but
it's like it's the idea of
you still have a choice as a writer of
how you want to introduce darkseid yeah
and you're like
here he is you want it oh there he goes
he's running away right
an era of mystery we don't really want
to meet him until we like meet him and
it's on and he's coming to earth and now
it's the fight we don't want to meet him
and then it's like
one day maybe next time gadget
like it is a kind of a claw feeling to
this where it's like all right you know
he's just gonna yeah we don't need to
see him like going through all of the
messages that assad has for him i think
it would be better just like notebooks
like oh and then he found like the
next mother box now he's looking for the
other two like that's not necessarily
the best way also to continue to have
him in the movie maybe you really just
want to wait until it's like he's here
and he's about to punch something in the
face
now again because this movie's four
hours long i don't feel like it was
taking away from time
used on action or character development
but i think if you were cutting it down
this would be
the first for me to go this is all of
these um
middle management reports i'm sorry mr
side is in a meeting can i take a
message
yeah it's just counter productive like
it actually hurts your overall goal
which is to make dark side
looming and scary like the big threat
that how are we ever going to defeat
i also think this is where the obsession
with evil superman kind of hurts you
because
in this movie especially like evil
superman's a more potent threat like
darkseid gets his ass kicked by ares
like
you know he needs all of this
information and plans to come together
to get here
superman at any moment could just be
like you know what screw you guys and
like that's it we're all doomed
like no one can beat superman so i feel
like you're almost
it's too much too much setup for stuff
that you know like is so way off
there you go all right let's keep
watching mighty dark sidekick no
protectors here
no lanterns equation is carved
into the surface of this very world
meanwhile batman is still assembling a
team of heroes to protect the earth
where they will work together to bring
back superman and quickly prove that
there's no point to a justice league
once you've brought back superman
honestly they have nothing to do besides
staying in a neat little line together
pause i think that that is uh uh people
are taking that
um not the spirit in which it was
written because yes
in the finale you do need cyborg to
separate the boozle boxes and you need
flash to run uh uh to moonwalk backwards
so fast that time goes back but in
general they made the
power gap between superman and everyone
else so explicit and so huge
uh with him kicking wonder woman's ass
like without breaking his sweat
and uh and the nightmare sequences and
the way he
solos steppenwolf like without again
breaking a sweat like with no problems
they've made him like it's superman in
the justice league
they've just set him up to be way too
uh far above all these other supposedly
you know
mythic uh pantheon of of heroes yeah and
they make it a point to let us know
um when he comes in and then when he
he's the one he can see the flash as he
moves that's definitely the point which
is like oh yeah well everybody's boned
now like there's nothing you can do
right he can defeat all of them
together no sweat and so it's kind of
like well then yeah
it's it can't help but put them all in a
supporting role i would especially say
you kind of highlighted some of this
every member of the justice league does
have a role
to play like wonder woman's the one who
knows about
who the dark side is the mother boxes
she's filling in all the backstory
cyborg is the guy who can actually get
into the mother boxes and kind of speak
to them
flash has the electrical charge power
superman's
obviously just the brute force that you
need um
aquaman no effort at all
put and like this is the old joke you
would think just because that's the
stereotype
that aquaman talked to some fish hahaha
he doesn't have any role here he likes
spears
guys and he's jason momoa i really feel
like it stands out like watching this
movie you're like
they couldn't have come up with a water
angle
they did there was like one moment where
uh that
facility started flooding and aquaman
was like oh oh yeah
but even then like he kind of holds it
off like he's
like he doesn't like save the day like
gives him a few extra seconds to escape
i don't know well the funny thing is
like kind of hand in hand with superman
being
so far and above everyone batman is so
far and above
below everyone as far as power set that
nobody is in any danger from uh
a an on-rushing wave of water except for
batman
i think wonder woman uh uh cyborg i mean
cyborg
but he's gonna be controlled he's the
project manager
batman's your your you know your ep like
there is no justice league without
batman he brought it all together so
like
he's got a role to play in this story
like this yeah but i think it's it's
pure vanity on batman's part that he's
not like an
oracle or an alfred oh he should
absolutely be like
at the computer like all right you guys
should go and yes he's
like they have to spend half their time
just like saving him or bringing him
along
and setting up like okay we need a
couple scenes explaining why he has some
new gauntlets that could uh keep him
alive
for a fraction of a second longer just
to get that scene with jeremy irons and
gal gadot where he's showing her his
gauntlets and then how to make tea
is like first of all she's like
thousands of years old and
from greece she knows how to make tea i
don't think
yeah but even when you've been working
in europe yeah the idea that an
old british guy knows how to make tea
better than a mediterranean goddess is
like
excuse you but um
but also that's what is that so like
even in a director's cut what is that
scene doing there
i feel like halfway through the scene it
feels like alfred's gonna break the
fourth wall and be like
you don't need to see this back to
master wayne like
come on i think you had to show that
like bruce was trying
to get on their level by making weapons
that look and feel like hers but that's
also
that's a five-second conversation to set
up when superman goes evil and batman
holds the gauntlet up i guess he thought
we'd be like
ain't no way batman's gauntlets can hold
off yeah silly vaporizer oh
if i show that that alfred made them
special then
no internet complaints that was for us
all right keep going
good job team okay soups take it from
here
with two and a half casablancas worth of
runtime to fill everyone's getting more
character depth
like aquaman who doesn't want to live
under the sea
but doesn't want to be where the people
are either because the surface world is
full of horny bjorks
the flash who's ditched the awkward
jokes dostoevsky
or awkwardly touching his wiener next to
iris west
batman who has so little to offer the
team they give him and alfred
a little airplane to work on as a treat
best minds away in aerospace couldn't
make it fly
oh christ wonder woman a goddess haunted
by her own relentless theme music
i have to bring up in the fake like
easter
or april fool's snyder cut fake out on
this trailer we did last year one of the
things that we sort of predicted was we
replaced a bunch of the like
funny catchphrase lines with dark
versions like i believe it was
uh mamoa saying like my man are we
replacing with
i'm sad i'm saying and uh
we then actually got to do that joke for
real
like like cyborg replaced his booyah
with [ __ ] the world
yeah the cyborg stuff i mean look yes he
was the emotional
core of the film even though it doesn't
start until about an hour and 20
into the film when you when it really
gets going um
and i think that there was i don't know
just a bit of a logic
bump for me of like
his life has been saved by his father
he saved his he thought he was dead and
he finds out that
actually no he's alive in a robot body
and he's instantly pissed i think that
you could have had like
a growing realization that okay maybe
this is actually i'm
a monster maybe this is more than i
bargained for but i think that
it could have been more powerful i think
if there if it started off with
the the joy and it like turns into
horror rather than
i'm alive and i [ __ ] hate it it sucks
this instantly sucks like come on you
get to fly
now you thought you were dead and you
can now control the stock market like
there's got to be some kind of fun in
there
take it take it at least take a test
drive or something like have some fun if
it does feel like when the kid is like
gifted the wrong car and like gets kind
of mad about it
oh it's also weird that he's already
like he's a before any of this happens
he is a like the most popular kid at
school football hero
and apparently like a brilliant computer
hacker
who was like and like a really good guy
like he was doing his hacking on behalf
of a fellow
student who you know was going through
grief and like had this loss like he's
compassionate and
it's just like it's it's it's more
interesting to give
a lot of power to someone who was not at
all power you know like the peter parker
of it
like it's such a power fantasy already
to be
vic stone and then to become cyborg i
just feel like it's like a hat on a hat
already like oh man if you're
vic stone starting quarterback for a d1
college
program right i mean you are you are
balling out so hard
like your life is not about you know oh
i gotta study from a test or
girls my dad's gonna be mad at me like
he's like he's like tim tebow times a
million
yeah it just it just seems like i don't
know you don't give yourself
like a lot of places to go when he's
already like a god
even when he's just like a mortal guy
you know like
i think that's kind of a it's a little
bit of a sniderian thing like
a person can't just be like good at
something they have to be like the best
like everything's got to be like
like you know eight adjectives for how
badass and awesome and cool and perfect
and amazing it is
and it's just like well that doesn't
give you a lot of places to go when
you're developing a character
yeah uh though i mean they uh quibbles
aside i think that they
um ray fisher did a great job certainly
he's certainly in this movie uh which
which is more than you can say about the
last one
and like i think a necessary presence
because like you said
everyone is at such a far removed
they're basically like carved into stone
and haha pun and he is um uh
you know he actually they make attempts
at humanizing him him in the flash but i
think a lot more successfully with
uh with cyborg um i don't i don't really
think any of our criticisms are aimed at
the
the performances like i i think these
are
i i i think it's always the the writing
and the
what they're doing what they can with
these slivers of character they're
they're being given yeah i think all the
performances yeah like affleck
ray fisher uh mamoa like they're not
being given a ton and they are
doing what they can like i don't know
none of these criticisms i think are
aimed at any of these actors
yeah i mean i don't want to single out
gal gadot but
um i feel like
she's kind of i mean and i guess it
makes sense for a 5 000 year old who's
seen it all but she kind of is
unchanging
see on a scene to scene whether it's
making tea with alfred or the return of
superman it's just always like
it's just kind of played the same she
she flourishes with a director who knows
how to
how to use her like she's like she's
been much better than this in other
movies that that's what else yeah
all right let's keep going here to
batman's mantle of depression who's lost
his body
lost his parents and might be the only
college football star to risk losing his
place on the team for academic
violations
that doesn't mean he can hack into our
system to change his friends grades
you know this dude plays for gotham you
and they just beat a big ten program
like wisconsin not only does he get a
pass for hacking grades
there's a 90 chance bruce wayne just
bought him an escalade
yeah the honest version of that scene is
that dean's like how can we keep this
secret repair
for snyder's trademark brand of muscular
visual filmmaking
packed to the bridge that's allergic to
their own shirts
flex the spikes i don't get it
here boo boo that woman
where every action scene got
immeasurably better thanks to new
additions
like amazon horse violence
atlantean bloodbending
the gods of olympus reminding darkseid
who's the daddy
extreme sesame seed close-ups
and heroes who take time to inspire the
next generation before their victims
brains have even finished dripping down
the walls can i be like you someday
you can be anything you want to be but
man at the risk of being
smell like corpses in that room so like
oh my
goodness just watched like 10 dudes get
brutally murdered
and that's before no you can't
this is right after somebody oh that's a
good point danielle no you cannot um
you're not a god
no you're not a god zeus's daughter i
don't care how many times you do you
scale the aggro crag you're never gonna
get up to being used as kid
it's just a sense of timing that i think
is just sometimes
missing a little bit uh i guess there's
like nowhere else to put beats like this
but it reminds me of when
superman was making out with lois in the
in the smoking
crater at the center of metropolis um
it's just there's a time and a place
zach and chris and or david goyer
whoever wrote that last one
there's a time and a place and just the
emotional through line of like these
kids are screaming for their life as a
terrorist
unloads on them with a full auto gun and
she's like ding ding ding ding ding
yeah they would all still be screaming
if not catatonic
and she's like i want to be just like
you yeah it's it's and i read i read uh
deborah and zach snyder did an interview
where they they were asked about that
scene where wonder woman like throws
dudes into wall's head first there's
like blood smear
and they were like well you got to show
the consequence like it's wrong to show
violence without consequences it's like
that then it's glamorizing the violence
like i get that i do
whoa i'm gonna i'm gonna stop you slash
them right there
it's glamorizing it when you do it in
slow-mo and like treat it like you're
watching like a living fresco of like
oh that's what i was gonna but you could
also set up the seat in a way that she
just like ties all those guys up or like
manages to take them out without
killing them all which i also feel like
character wise
is what wonder woman would do especially
in front of a room full of children like
that's part of the character is that
you're not just going to like
brutally murder all of these dudes and i
know that the response is always like
well but she
she has to or they're going to blow up
the city it's like but all these
scenarios are like that's what he's
writing like that's what they're coming
they're coming up with a scenario that
requires wonder woman to like
kill 10 guys not that it has to tie in
but you saw post
or wonder woman 1984 i think it opened
with like a a child endangerment
scenario and she
laughed not that this should have
happened in the snyder cut though it
would have been hilarious if like a
guy's like spinning around in like a
mall display like
exactly you can obviously kind of
actually whatever you want and it's a
choice to make it this brutal
and uh in front like and to make it
brutal like
batman kill it like oh okay it doesn't
bother me that much but
in front of a room full of children it's
it's a it's a weird vibe that whole
scene is just very odd that it's so
i think that nine well we'll see in
wonder woman 94 what what changed you
know maybe she got really into
uh net it's just gonna be the same but
she's gonna have a flannel around her
waist she just watches living single all
day
[Laughter]
all right keep going eating a dead
superman this guy
loves his slow motion
i mean come on the flash's super speed
gets the same treatment as lois lane
putting down a cup of coffee
is her drink going back in time or she
just extra sad about her husband
there's a big so gather round for the
epic culmination of a mass movement
built around the sincere belief that it
wasn't enough for zack snyder to do
whatever he wanted for two box office
disappointments
it's not enough that grim superhero
storytelling is basically its own genre
now
no this film had to exist in its purest
form
or rather this film always existed in
its purest form
and the 70 million dollars warner spent
on it was for uh
snacks or something but now that it's
finally here
snyder's biggest fans can finally lay
down their arms
and be satisfied that their hero's
journey got a proper ending
oh come on so wave as you pass by
uh you know not that i will join in or
or support you know bombing everybody's
twitter feed but why wouldn't they do it
again why wouldn't they keep going it
worked
yeah i mean this is why you don't
negotiate with terrorists
because then they then you're just like
uh you're
saying well terrorism works like they do
do a terrorism on us and we'll
we'll cave you know like that's that's
what happened yeah yeah really
skywriting obviously this is not on the
same level as actual terrorism
uh a bit but of course snyder fans have
that appreciation for nuance that we're
that we're using here
i'm just saying that's why this is the
same as terrorism i'm saying the tactic
is the same yeah um yeah i mean i can
i i'm trying to think of other
situations where
this is like i mean yeah people there's
like hashtags that get things
to manifest in the real world all the
time yeah we've been
nerds we have been doing this forever i
remember when it was like brown coats
get together and do stuff there was one
show i wish i could remember off the top
of my head where they were like
mail a penny mail a penny to their
offices and like say that this is what
you want and we'll get it so this is
like
it's just the first time something this
notable has worked because usually it
just like
they might get another season if it's a
tv show just because they're showing
interest but usually this doesn't work
so yeah yeah i i think that like people
who are diehard marvel
i gotta say die hard marvel fans will
will never do this because i feel like
they've been trained to just be happy
with whatever comes out
like yay yeah like there's nothing that
they
that they would demand i can't think of
like a uh
well now i'm trying to think star wars
fans definitely have a there's some
hashtags to be
from the star wars side of things so
much of this does seem to come down to
on some ways a cult of personality like
more so than an idea or a pitch for what
the universe should be or like that kind
of a notion
it's the idea of rallying behind a
creator that seems to get a lot of this
going like
like it was the zack snyder-ness of it
that i think rallied this community so
strongly the fact that he was there
on vero like encouraging people and
posting things and teasing and
momoa was joining in and ray fisher
obviously like i think that was a big
part of it
and so i think you you do see that in
star wars that it tends to be either
beloved or
divisive controversial figures that tend
to become lightning rods for this and i
think you would see it with marble too
it would just have to be kevin fein like
yeah and i think that this could only
like you said this could only work for
um
something on the wb side because i think
that like
as a filmmaker you've already
compromised by uh
making a disney film i just think that i
don't mean that like in an
insulting way i just think that there
are there are certain considerations you
have to make
for franchises as a whole and things you
can and can't do in the ways you can and
can't play with these characters
that like if you've signed on to make a
marvel movie
you've i guess it's like edgar wright
would be the last time somebody tried to
do their own thing and paid the price
but in this
day and age it's like you know here's
the tools you have to work with and like
you're either going to play ball or not
like i just think you can you can do no
mad land or you could do eternals and
there's like
obviously it's a very different scenario
in terms of
how much of your own creative control
you have over what you're doing
yeah um so yeah i think
that's just facts people um so i think
it is
uh it's cool that this happened for
a filmmaker even if it's one that
doesn't uh resonate with me i am in
favor of filmmakers getting to do
their own thing and actually put their
vision up on the screen
and like i don't think any of us have an
issue with
filmmakers getting to do their
definitive versions of their movies or
getting to see new versions or cuts of
things that we like or even
passionate fan campaigns i think what so
much of the
reaction to this group and this movement
in particular
was how negative and toxic
and aggressive it became well it's just
it's not everybody that's not the whole
group
the humor of it is to me at least is
that it's the same level of seriousness
with which zack snyder treats these
characters
and if you don't share that seriousness
if in
your mind batman and superman are of the
same
level of respect in your life as bazooka
joe or
archie it just strikes you as a little
bit silly
that that this is such a passionate and
such like a grim
serious cause uh so taking a step back
that's where i find it uh that's where i
find the fun in it
um sure but enough about that let's move
on because we still got like seven parts
left that we're clearly setting up
multiple sequels
teasing fans with the ultimate fantasy
of watching darkseid and superman take
the rest of earth to pound town
ensuring that every tweet article or
public statement about warner brothers
will get swarmed with a hashtag restore
the snyder verse something that will
never
ever happen until dc's annual firing of
the executives and the next ones make it
happen
bullying remains undefeated y'all wait
it's still not over
that was a natural place to stop welcome
entirely new additions like martian
manhunter
whose appearance raises questions like
where the [ __ ] has martian manhunter
been
and how often does he hit the town
disguised as diane lane and jared leto's
joker finally sharing a scene with ben
affleck's batman
i mean they clearly didn't film together
but you can imagine what it would be
like if they finally shared a scene
who's gonna give you a reach around it
would suck
okay this thing is way too long and i've
been holding in p since part four
can you just roll every time they say
mother box i'll be right back
[ __ ] mother boxers mother
boxing mother boxes mother box
mother boxes mother boxes mother boxes
mother boxes
motherboards mother boxes
ah that's better all right time for
storing
daddy warbats i'm rich wonder woman
restorer of ancient art and antiquities
never mind it's not a phase mom this is
who i am now
every heist team needs an i.t guy debbie
drowner
i want to be left alone this is a bad
idea his father's dead because of us
quip silver mr t put the water in first
so we don't scrawl the tea that's
probably enough tea
and then leave it to mash big city elegy
pause infuriated that you didn't go with
tea prepared there
that's that's such a good joke for that
beat
what is this what is this reference
jeremy irons uh
played scar in the original um lion king
and that's the song is be prepared that
he sings
you know i always tune out during the
villain songs
those are the most skippable songs be
prepared
i know be prepared not lying for line
lon i've heard the song
it's the chorus
[Laughter]
i even wrote in the notes i even wrote
allah the lion king
and then t pre and then all caps
pear tea prepared
it got 150 likes on twitter and like
well everyone give uh send his roses
and uh oh boy and just imagine t and
then we just go with mr t
it's like even a t joke i didn't get it
i'm sorry you know i don't i should have
thought you're right i should have
fought harder for it
yeah there's there's only a thousand
pages to to juggle through on this one
you gotta flag it like that and i know
listen
sometimes i write song starrings and
then we don't do them just because it's
a little you know it's
also yes john bailey extremely talented
voice actor
can do any voice in the world what are
the top voice men in the business it's a
lot to ask to also
sing as well i don't like to give him
too many musical things
to do but in this case i thought it was
funny yeah
all right all right keep going minus 10
minutes
is this movie rushing or dragging it's
dragging maybe this guy should stop
working with robots
the boar is lava i'm made of rocks as
you can see
i don't let that intimidate you martha
manhunter
the living joke meera's accent
the first born of beloved queen atlanta
you are the
first born son of queen atlanta and your
mama's box is so smelly steppenwolf can
track it halfway across the globe
you have been near a mother box the
scent is on you
oh justice league bigger longer and
uncut
working on an id sketch
where did they find that sketch artist
the leprechaun guy
i think we all cracked up when they when
they threw that one up on the screen
during the watch long
it's weird because it's like well
wouldn't that a professional sketch
artist have been drawing it so shouldn't
it look a little bit
better like that like the big hazmat
gloves on
well they're wearing goggles like that
you would think if nothing else you
would get the circular eyes and the
teeth
it it had to be bad enough that it could
be batman
or a or a bug man yeah so i guess i
don't know yeah but still that was that
was pretty silly
um god so i guess that there's things
that we cut
i believe that was one of the longest
ones we've done in a while but let's see
what didn't make it in he's so op snyder
will take any excuse to turn soups evil
you know somewhere in the multiverse
zack just adapts the injustice games and
makes everyone happy
anyone else starring
the dark knight advises imagine all the
heroes
fighting in a league clark after dark
the corpse husband the fantastic mr box
wet and pushy hey that's littering
arrest him batman
adobe flash time bandit iron's man
amy sadams prickly pete all horned up
for mother's box
batman give me a picture of spider-man
okay hold for darkseid one moment please
shamose a hero that would have been
useful yesterday
the green screen of crime the do-over
and there you have it um yeah not much
not much was left on the cutting room
play i think that the idea was to just
throw everything at the wall i'll uh the
snyder cut you know
with the parts the chapter headings uh
if it's too long you know you
pause after chapter three and then and
then come back and finish it's treat it
like a mini series come back to it
it'll be there waiting um uh
it uh i believe it's that time to to
wade into
uh the comment section so let's see
let's see what hashtag restore the spy
the starter verse we know
gosh where to begin um let's see uh
this isn't in there but was that john
doing the taiko a td right like that's
not taiko with
audio i wanted to confirm that yeah you
did a great job yeah
uh yeah he really did he really nailed
the korg voice
we try to play to his strengths i don't
i don't try to make the man sing unless
i have to
yeah james zuniga writes uh should the
lesson of the movie be number one
finishing remaking or retconning a movie
won't make it better or two
it totally works now and remake episode
8 in episode 9 of star wars
well i think those are two different
situations right
um i feel like ryan
johnson did make his his version of star
wars so
who's retcon who's remaking it like this
is a kind of a unique thing where
a film was taken from its director and
i mean you could remake episode nine
with ryan johnson i'm sure that would
make everyone happy
i think that in general people are too
precious about
remakes like every time a new remake is
announced it's always like
oh wow like i even saw this today they
announced spiral
the new like reboot of the saw franchise
and people were just like
let it die and it's like so it's not
that great to begin with you don't need
to let it die for its own sake like
let's try it again who knows maybe
maybe we'll figure out a better way to
better take on it like
so i'm just generally like i'm not ever
bothered or offended by the idea of
remake so if we wanted to just start
like
remake movies that were from not that
long ago and let another director have
their spin on it like
i'm i'm honestly fine with that like i
think that would be fun like why not let
it let three more directors
give us another take on star wars
sequels like
i'd go see them i think um
just for the first question in this is
should the lesson of this movie be
uh you know finishing remaking or
recounting a movie won't make it better
in this case it did make it better i
mean it's there
it did make it a better movie so i don't
know if that's the lesson we necessarily
come away with
um because this is leagues better
than um the first justice league was it
just is
it's not it's the it's it's not a it's
not a like reconsideration or remake
like
it's like they gave the movie to
somebody else and he mucked it up and
this is more like a rest
a little bit more like a restoration so
at to spencer's point
it's sort of somewhere in the middle i
don't know if you could base a
future principle off of what happened
here because that's such a weird
situation
yeah but you're right it's obviously
like like i would much rather watch
this one than the 2017 one uh
arthur mingo writes uh i have a question
why does chris tario not get blame and
only zack snyder and i
wholeheartedly agree arthur
i do think that zack snyder is a
incredible visual filmmaker he knows how
to frame
these heroes and make it look epic and
awe inspiring and like what it would
really look like if
superman was fighting zod through
metropolis like that's he can really
put that on screen in front of you and i
think my main issue with these films is
is usually the dialogue it's usually the
the plotting and it's like you know of
course
it's like i said it's annoying when
marvel goes too far
into the quippy like oh that just
happened
of it all but it's also really boring
when
some of these dc movies go too far into
like
now we must we must form a league and
now
you to my side and i will become the
king of the world
no you will become well i will stop you
and it's just like
it's the dialogue is just surface it's
just telling you what they're thinking
and what they're going to do to you and
if this happens then that's going to
happen it's just not
compelling writing to me and i placed
that mostly at the blame of
uh of the of the screenwriter not the
director
this is normally the spot where i would
be like look these kind
like this is as much an organizational
project as it is a creative project like
a movie like this
and so i sympathize with a person who's
brought in to be like
make sense of this whole shared universe
and bring all these disparate
stories and characters together but i'm
not going to say that in this case
because chris terrio
also co-wrote dawn of justice and he's
inheriting all of the problems that he
set up for himself
in the previous movie so he gets no
sympathy for me at all
it's like he got he got multiple movies
he just inherited man of steel and we
got this like
crazy chaotic mess of a thing and it's
like
this this story doesn't need to be this
convoluted like if you're gonna spend
four hours telling this story
the focus should be on these characters
and making us care about these
relationships
not on explaining mother boxes to us 18
times they're
it's they're three boxes you gotta keep
them apart that's it it's very simple
more than one scene that's all it is
don't let the boxes touch or it's the
end of the world oh okay that makes
sense
okay i get it all right okay when do we
need to hook into them and do we need to
like no just keep them apart
keep them apart wendigo 2064 rfi right
my biggest question for the film were
those the most expensive fake hot dogs
of all time
and i would say no because well i wonder
if that scene's budget
equaled the entire budget of sausage
party someone will have to figure that
out
i think that might technically rogan
really should have voiced that hot dog
that barry puts in his pocket
[Laughter]
oh so i want to hear seth rogen's laugh
in slow motion
all right and pedro benitez right i
don't think i heard anything positive
towards the movie in the trailer well i
i disagree i can pick on some favorites
lots of stuff but
i think we definitely point out how much
better it is than the whedon version
uh yes and then um let's see he says uh
what was each one of your
favorite parts um i liked all the amazon
stuff i thought the amazon stuff was
great especially like extended and when
we do get horse fighting
um yeah that was easily my favorite part
was everything with the amazons that we
got to see now
i agree the stuff that's added inside
where
it's like steppenwolf shows up and then
they're sealing the vault and
hippolyta has to like scooch out like
that that's
much better in the new version i uh i
will say it was it was
both extremely crazy
but so specific to zack snyder uh that i
that i loved it would be the
midwintar uh norwegian aquaman farewell
ceremony scene like it's so weird and
out of nowhere and it
once you start thinking about it you're
like wait he's the first aquaman and
he's like
40 years old or a little younger so they
just started doing this a few years ago
like this is not an ancient village
right that these guys do every year when
aquaman
comes this is like a spontaneous thing
that happened
no he he has them all rehearsed uh he's
been working hey i'm gonna take off but
when i go do you guys mind
singing a little song about me while i
go and like oh
you can smell my shirt if you wanna
surprise you're a little pitchy
and i will i will echo and and call out
uh
a very clear uh compliment in the script
where every action scene got
immeasurably better and i fully agree
with that i i can't
pick a favorite because they all got
more sensible and
cooler looking and that should be the
core of a justice league film
if you're gonna make it you want to see
all the justice league in action and man
he nailed it like
every time steppenwolf raided a
different you know building or temple or
whatever
it became like this incredible back and
forth and just this amazing action
sequence
um the flash one little odd choice with
the wieners
um but still but otherwise seems really
weird too because it's a funny scene
like he's he's trying to get this
job at the pet store and it's amusing
and then he's gonna go savor it becomes
like he plays this really somber needle
drop and it becomes this really sad
scene while he saves iris
and then it's immediately back to being
funny again where there's there's too
much time between
plucking the wiener and paying off the
wiener joke wow there's like there's too
much time between
much time and i will quickly just uh i
took the song to be
it almost felt like in romeo and juliet
when they're meeting each other through
the glass that was kind of what i felt
the song was evoking for me i don't know
if that was on purpose right
yes you're you are correct in the
context of that scene he's seeing
uh this is gonna become uh this is iris
you know it's like his love for the
franchise
but i don't i don't feel like they sell
that in the movie and it just feels like
the pacing is off and it's weird but yes
i'm sure conceptually it was
well he's falling in love with this
woman who will become his love interest
in the
in the subsequent film that we're still
waiting on maybe one day but yeah he is
uh just to reiterate he's a titanically
talented visual filmmaker and director
of
of huge superhero action scenes i think
that
i prefer it to really any third act
marvel movie where it's just kind of
these globs of armies smashing into each
other i think
that's why we go that far but i i would
say the
the others the other moment that now
stands out to me is when the flash is
like running backwards through time and
everything is like filling
in around him that's right yeah yeah so
there you go i think uh look i think if
you're looking us
looking for us to be super positive
about any comic book movie
uh you it's gonna be tough to find it's
gonna be tough to find something that we
have no notes
on but that's part of the fun uh i hope
it's uh received in the same good
nature in which it was intended i'm sure
it will be um but that's our first we
all left into the spider verse
we did all of spider-verse and i ha and
if you have anything bad to say about
japanese spider-man i will fight you oh
yeah yeah
i am the defender of planet spy miter
yeah um so we
we've got another epic uh clash next
week
for honest trailers to tease for you
guys um it's on the level of batman vs
superman
so it's something equally powerful uh
coming at you next week
and wow i think we're just over an hour
which means i have to go juan danielle
thank you for hanging out with me people
thank you for watching please like
please subscribe if you've hung around
this long
and uh we'll talk about the snyder cut
again i'm sure
i'm sure better tomorrow
but keep the conversation going and uh
and we'll see you guys soon thanks for
watching
[Music]
you